citizens of the reject Nation we are
back joined by the Terra Erickson hello
hello what are we watching today Tara be
Fantastic Four the second one Rise of
the Silver Surfer neither of us have
seen this movie if you didn't catch our
reaction before the upstairs first time
watching in my first time re-watching
after like I don't know 15 20 or
something like that people say this one
is better I'm looking forward to this
right here right now first order
business go ahead leave a like we know
how that feels Tara what do they do ring
that Bell
ring ring ring ring ring ring ring the
subscribers are coming did you just turn
into the Hunchback of another day that's
what I did and lastly full length three
action watch long recent their own copy
of Fantastic Four resin Silver Surfer
we're watching this on the D Plus
available for super sexy Rejects at our
patreon page massive thank you to all
who have joined us it's been coming so
much stuff lately oh we're still cover
many things exclusively over there with
reaction highlights and Watch Dogs
included enough chit chatting let's
watch watching
[Music]
is this a volcano they were looking at a
planet
[Music]
oh that's Doom and Gloom whoa
there he is whoa
that's cool it's like an actual alien
coming to Earth
this is the surfing silver
ah neat
whoa
cool that's awesome
all their diversity out in the first few
minutes
that's where we live
oh we don't get anything fun we just get
a power outage okay
created weddings a fantastic couple Reed
Richards and Susan storm will take place
this Saturday oh neat unbelievable
it's happening again isn't it yeah sure
we're not postponing anything not this
time this is going to be the wedding
you've always dreamed of and I'm not
going to let anything get in the way of
that this is what's really at stake
just a little hobby of mine yeah I'm
gonna make a good toy or is it something
uh sciency I bet it flies I better flies
do you think it surfs in silver
so listen I have a very important
wedding issue I need to talk to you
about bachelor party your bachelor party
yeah yeah man get it frankly I think Sue
might have a problem
somebody told her that you were actually
investigating Global disturbances and
Cosmic radiation instead of actually
focusing on the wedding isn't this
important though
like apart
I've got a wedding to go to a bachelor
party could be fun but no exotic dancers
that's the whole point of the bachelor
party though right
that's what I tried telling my wife
uh wedding was delayed
[Music]
Doom
cookie
exotic dancers what are they
you're Mr Fantastic
that is so awesome
I didn't realize this was going to turn
into a fast and furious film I think
it's worse if they're not strippers
and they're coming on him
they're just really really hot single
women yeah
good evening and welcome
can I help you
no you can't use that element oh I love
him
oh my God
and then
it exploded and in a trillionth of a
second it expanded exponentially is what
became the universe we know today you
really put your powers to waste
I don't think they're just hot single
girls
we think they're escorts
he is really dancing
foreign
it's got that smolder going
uh oh oh you came at the worst time he
had never hugged those girls until just
now
I was just explaining to the girls
don't say bang
you can buy one of our spy satellites
three days ago
if we're gonna find out what this is all
about we need a way to locate and
intercept that object might it be
possible to build a sensor tie it into
the Baxter building satellite grid and
we can pinpoint the exact location of
the object you see I'm getting married
this Saturday your country needs your
help the world needs your help the
wedding is that important I know
serious threat happening
about what you saw back at the bar worry
about it
I know you I'm glad you had fun
didn't seem like that after she walked
in it was nothing compared to what I did
on my bachelorette party
foreign
Wild
she could get away with more because
she's invisible
she probably didn't even have one Greg
no it's a little game
oh
you're making that thing for the general
okay don't tell Johnny
don't tell Johnny what
that's why I know don't worry
then sticking together lying to your
woman lie to that woman you're gonna
marry man for Science and our country
oh
[Music]
Stanley
named Stanley oh it's going by Stanley
nice try buddy not really I'm Stan Lee
so Marvel Comics exists in this world is
my life always going to be a circus do
you love Reed more than I've ever loved
anyone and you have nothing to worry
about the scientist is always concerned
with her woman problems General I'm
putting the sensor online
now
this is good you can attract the Silver
Surfer to your wedding cool
I like drama
seems like he was avoiding
the fear who is just burying it deep
down
[Music]
oh my God Doom's become a hyper
scientist you know you don't look
completely ridiculous in that dress
is that obnoxious brother talk for you
look kind of nice
you look beautiful
that's your sister you creep lay off it
man you're related
dad would be proud
oh that's sweet let's get an actual
tender moment between them
you shut your cell phone off actually
[Music]
the cosmic radiation can wait I've got a
wedding and as established throughout
this entire movie The Wedding is the
most important
we are gathered here today to join this
couple Reed Richards together
okay
in the bond
holy
mantra
Reed seriously pull your [__] together
we brought that thing
I know but there's a good reason
we have to get through this quickly
oh my God how many kinds of Love let me
just get to the end please oh my God
Reed what bro can't you control it from
your phone
all those people the wedding are gonna
die now via helicopter
[Music]
whoa that looks awesome
that's terrifying that's so scary oh my
goodness cool
ah oh my God
[Music]
ice versus fire
oh neat oh that's cool
yes oh awesome oh that is cool
[Music]
oh it looks great
what
[Music]
it's a cool sequence
can we talk
what you doing man talk
you win
whoa
[Music]
oh no oh man
another world awaits
let it be done quickly
it looked like a man but completely
covered in silver and it was flying this
like like a surfboard type thing I know
that sounds crazy so did you follow the
shiny man to Lollipop Land or the
Rainbow Junction
to radiate cosmic energy when it exerts
itself randomly affecting matter
evidently this entity this Silver Surfer
destroyed the sensor
we're dealing with something highly
resourceful so it's your fault the
wedding was ruined I'm not I'm not mad
that you built this
it's like
a correlation
sorry and assuming she's gonna be like
don't do this thing
see this proves exactly what I've been
saying all along could you drop the
force fields please
oh okay never mind I'd say get back
we will never have normal lives as long
as we do what we do
how could we possibly raise a family
like this
they would be so lucky yeah they'd have
like a little superhero babies like The
Incredibles
Johnny getting humbled this movie does
he have like a silver sickness
[Music]
Johnny are you okay
maybe we should get you checked out
I didn't do anything what is going on
what
they're transferring powers
just hang on I'll get you okay
[Music]
no what's going on
how did this happen
well where is Johnny here
oh no oh heck yeah
oh
me because you're the hot one oh yeah
it's a hot one this should be every
moment of the movie
ideally I'd like to run some more tests
do you like to fall into yeah no no no
no no no no no no hey
I just wanted to give him a hug
it could be fun hey
hey it's me I'm back you've always had
the cape they have the machine
what am I supposed to do in the meantime
just uh try to keep your distance from
us promise
[Music]
trying to figure out who he's serving I
feel like it was the meteor or the thing
because he looked at that orange ball in
the sky and then he was like I serve you
just ignore it there's no getting away
from it I believe there is
what if
after this crisis is over we leave it
all behind we quit
I'll take a teaching position somewhere
the two of us will live our lives and
raise a family like normal people
it's not all that's cut out to be you're
a superhero all right you're supposed to
save people in the comics they have kids
really and it goes splendidly oh well I
didn't realize this turned into
Pleasantville you've been busy my friend
your talents are impressive
can you understand what I'm saying
I'm silver I'm not dumb
all that you know is at an end
wait
I said
oh you're in for it now buddy
whoa oh I thought it killed him yeah I
thought so too he like disintegrated
into Ash and what a nice normal boring
ass life what do they expect us to do
keep it going just the two of us and
call ourselves what the dynamic duo ah
everywhere the surfer goes eight days
later and Planet dies now we're gonna
stop him
what about the craters interesting the
craters is what I meant I think he's
serving the crater it seems like a
Galactus situation you know Galactus
yeah I I know all about galaxies I've
never heard of echolactus being in this
so I don't think so when I see silver
I'm hitting them wait you can't do that
we've got to stick to the plan and work
as a team oh so we're a team now that's
news to me what are you talking about
you know what I'm talking about
yeah you know
this really isn't a good time kids got a
point Reed you should have told them all
right all right that's enough we'll talk
about this later what the hell is wrong
with you people
yeah every fight is like wedding family
let's fight about it
why don't they just focus on being
superheroes for a minute
[Music]
damn sue your powers are impeccable
oh
this effects are pretty good man
yeah Johnny do exactly
[Music]
what a dumb dumb
oh my God you're a better Human Torch
yeah
science man
I wouldn't just give a head not if
someone saved my life
I'd be like thank you so much thank you
so much was this like Pleasant head knot
look we have an understanding
I like that this one has an actual
threat though
threat yeah there's an actual threat
here we'll make adjustments next time
we'll be ready you can't handle this
alone
that's why I'm bringing in some help
General you bringing more soldiers and
weaponry you're going to put innocent
people in danger no more than you
already have no [__]
oh my God it's face what's the matter
afraid of ghosts
it's clobber in time we need to work
together to survive you trust Victor and
you're gonna regret it so far the only
one I've regretted trusting here is you
he's done so much for you
built a sensor they save those people
from the dying eye
the energy was channeled through him but
it originated from his board if we can
separate him from the board
we can cut off his power completely
Doom is smarter this time
I gotta tell you man I'm starting to
feel like a complete screw-up hey hey I
mean
you kind of are
you want to spend your last few minutes
I'd like to spend my last couple of
minutes holding
exactly
that sounds pretty good
I mean not the holding Alicia thing
that's you know I can't even think of a
guy that wouldn't want it
what I meant
was that it's just nice to have somebody
coming around to it it's gonna be all
right you have no it won't be the whole
world's counting on me and I just you
just need to relax yeah right you do
you need to relax
take a deep breath
slower
there you go
you can already feel your pulse slowing
down oh so it's Paul's town a tachyon
pulse
you did you did relax slow down learn
some information have a thought when we
activate the field it'll separate him
from his board making him powerless it's
like a fish in a net I can only go so
fast since apparently I'm working by
myself
now you son of a [__] what are you
doing you're
you know sue you could go invisible and
just kind of stalk yeah that's true then
she's got to put back on all her clothes
it's a whole ordeal Greg did you know I
could create a force field inside
someone's body and expand it until they
explode
if it's your best shot
at least there's like real scenes in
this movie too
wrestler for in 10 minutes with or
without you will you just waiting
outside the bathroom to try and catch me
in a towel
I was joking
why are you so down on me you don't even
know me actually I know you very well
there's showers in the middle of an
office all I've seen is a guy that
almost got his team killed I've been a
little off my game lately this is not a
game
I do like the emphasis on Johnny you're
truly maturing
learning it's real life it's not a game
Johnny
you blew it this is a military what you
freaking fart Jesus Christ what what so
let me make it clear for you and your
pack of freaks here I'm the quarterback
you're on my team
got it
pack of freaks but I guess you never
played football in high school did you
winches what is this guy's personality
I'm one of the greatest minds of the
21st century and the big jock who played
quarterback in high school
but he's standing right in front of me
asking me for my help and I say he's not
gonna get a damn thing unless he does
exactly what I tell him
yes yeah yes lay down the law starchy
boy
give him what he wants
all right that was easy
I'm so hot for you right now me too
[Music]
I have a problem
he's here
it's Surf and silver
don't touch her
oh oh wow oh yep why are you destroying
our planet I have no choice there's
always a choice I am
not Roger out
oh
it's
he's protecting her yeah
whoa it's pretty awesome that's very
cool I mean the way they realize the
silver server is pretty cool all right
it's up fishnet
[Music]
thank you
oh Doom
uh
it's interesting how he morphs into like
practical design
we have work to do I want to be there
for the questioning that's not gonna
happen
please make sure our guests remain here
you need the scientists
there are certain things I'm not
permitted to do because they're
considered human rights violations
you're not human
I like the makeup yeah he looks awesome
he protected me from the missile why
would he do that we need to get inside
there and talk to him under the radar
if only there is clothes off lady
get stealthy the popcorn or something
just to pass the time I'll call it in Mr
Stone great thank you
you said you weren't the one trying to
destroy our world
then who is the one I serve who do you
serve you have to tell me the truth who
do you serve man come on
it is known by many names
why people called it
Galactus it is Galactus
devour worlds yep all the worlds and
innocent people you've helped destroy my
service
spares my world and the one I love
how interesting why did you try to
protect me
You Remind Me
of her
account looks like Val Kilmer yeah
it is not iron I who draws the Destroyer
here
it is the beacon what's the beacon
the source of my power
you're bored
I think he thinks I'm talking to someone
take joy in the last few hours you have
left
for he is nearly here
okay so
yes oh it is Galactus oh that's cool I
saw the shape I helped deliver the alien
to you as promised now it's time to keep
your end of the bargain you can do your
tests on the board
and in my presence only
absolutely
he's gonna get all sorts of doomy and
it's just gonna bring more do me drama
thank you
you guys deserve it for how you treat it
read yep
[Music]
how did you devise this
look at him shaking
[Music]
oh boy
whoa
breed
huh we need to get the surfer he's the
only one that understands its power even
if we break him out of this place how
are we gonna catch up the victor
leave that to me I'm a scientist
the jet is it the jet pull that cover
off baby and show us what you got
[Music]
cool where is General Hager dead
come out of here we're all gonna be
listen to me I'm smarter than hot why is
nobody like it's fond Doom girl
[Music]
Booyah this is by far the coolest thing
you have ever done
[Music]
that is pretty cool
I did dope are you serious are we lucky
at the sinking carry I could fly circles
around you
shut up
I'm driving
[Music]
does he need to say flame on he didn't
when he was saving the London Eye which
is why I said it so I don't really know
Victor is out there somewhere with
unlimited power and we've got a giant
Intergalactic Force that's about to
destroy our planet in less than 24 hours
I've got a lock on Victor's energy nice
expositional recap
[Music]
what the hell was that fixer the board
is drawing the Destroyer here you have
to give it up you know I've never been
the giving type read
hahaha
it's like a Power Rangers villain now
[Music]
holy [__] junk we're gonna have to split
up what this ought to be fun stay close
to me cool
[Music]
really pissing me off Metalhead
nice yeah
[Music]
you guys are becoming International
terrorists destroying artifacts left and
right
catch
[Music]
no
what just happened uh oh
he's gonna catch you and give us okay
he's not
Doom you're being a [__] yeah he's
being stupid right now like really
stupid I think there's got to have a
pulse in there linking him to his board
we take it out he's too strong for me I
could will on him if I could get close
enough that he could see me coming from
a mile away
touch her she's dying you'll become
invisible or maybe just one of us we
don't know what it could do to you
let's not make this about me it's time
to become selfless he's a growing boy
[Music]
quote a friend of mine
it's clobber in time oh my God he's
combined Powers Yeah
smart he's like a snake he's like Jafar
[Music]
there we go
you ain't going down fighting kid
thank you
fun good luck swimming and all that
metal buddy he'll find a way they always
do
so Doom's just like an entity this time
around I mean uh Galactus
[Music]
they didn't just do it did they what
can he just touch her and she'll heal
like when Von Doom first touched him he
started to heal up right uh he needs his
board oh yeah right the whole board
thing
all right there we go
oh
let me take my sweet time
now save the girl
gotta go
not before I save her because she
reminded me of the one
there we go
[Music]
treasure each moment with her
and tell her she was right yes we do
have a choice that's cool surfing silver
that's great
[Music]
I think the
serious moments it's so much better with
this one huh
I thought you could use a hand oh my God
what's the Silver Surfer gonna do
how could it how could he how did he
stop it
I will know
sir yeah talk some sense into them
oh
he sacrifices himself
these are some great visuals
see his face there it is
[Music]
that looks awesome
priced like
thank you
all right
surfing silver you thought he was the
bad guy but now he's the hero
what I miss
she is ridiculously attractive
she is
hey wait
hey
changing
that's right hug him oh
so I guess this is it
we all go our separate ways if it wasn't
for the team the whole world would be
gone by now we can't run away from our
responsibilities and the people we need
to protect yeah you jackasses why would
you dare questions what about having a
normal life a family who says you have
to be normal to have a family yeah
Welcome to The Incredibles but the four
credibles
[Music]
they want this to get released in China
is
going on here
I guess so or is this Japanese am I
racist
you know nothing
science is sinking into the Adriatic oh
boy can we
can we just to the end oh cute call back
I Now Pronounce your man and wife and
you may kiss the bride
hey all right
we should get out of here yeah she came
around
I do like this one more yes
but only because of the ending
she's gonna catch it and he's gonna be
like uh oh
[Applause]
burn them
that's great
yeah well now you know
reflex
[Music]
right four in the sky
yeah waste your time
[Music]
foreign
skip to the end was the best call back
in this movie
we shall see if there is a post credit
scene well well well
oh
he lives
there it is his eyes open do you see
that no
then the board flew to him so it's a
sign that he's alive so he's like big
and huge and stronger now because he's
living with Galactus inside of him and
he's also surfing silver
so he's like a galactic Surf and surf in
Galactus I don't know
that's I know he's a surfing Galactus
now let's talk about it well Tara you
have officially experienced a Fantastic
Four I have franchise
um what did you think about it everyone
thought you hated the last one
I didn't ate it but I didn't hate this
one it got good in the middle and the
end and the callbacks are my favorite
once they combine Powers I was like yeah
there was too much yelling at Reed I was
like there is no reason for this guy to
be so upset at Reed Reed has only ever
done the right thing and built you the
thing and been around with his his
lackeys trying to help you out man uh so
that part I did not feel as Justified I
feel like I mean the Army people yeah
yeah yeah like yelling at him so much I
forget what his name was but the
sergeant yelling at Reed just like left
and right I was like why this is that's
the part I didn't like because I didn't
feel like I was justified like it was a
little odd it was just out of nowhere
once you do this fulfill this fulfill
this you made one mistake oh my God
you're punished rough and we're bringing
in Von Doom now yeah uh yeah but
otherwise I had I had fun I did like
this one better this one felt like a
real movie to be yeah yeah they have
more real moments right yeah yeah this
this one felt more confident more
assured in how they handled the
direction
um I like the way it was shot better it
looked better the comedy did not get
better for me no but this movie took
itself more serious overall and that
actually worked better for me yeah and I
I like that everyone's chemistry a lot
more like everything I thought it was
actually other than it didn't get
funnier for me I did like the bouquet
moment a lot at the very end that was
great that was a good moment that was
hilarious but the rest of it I agree
with you I didn't really laugh that much
like when uh he gets into the wall and
he's like oh that hurt and yeah so I'm
back here I was like this isn't it's not
hitting home for me yeah a lot of the
comedy felt a little uh the comedy felt
more off to me in fact that's where I
felt the movie was a tad bit at odds
with itself like I liked the first time
I like the first time the switching of
powers happens like when Jessica Alba is
a fire that that was funny
um when Reed's firstly rushing through
the wedding that was fine there's like
so few moments that I thought were
actually funny that I can recall what
each one of those is yeah like the first
time Chris Evans become uh gets the
thing uh Powers was fun so yeah oh but I
thought there was actual Stakes this
time around yeah it was focused it did
because it it had like a clear threat in
villain throughout
um I thought the visuals were actually
great they were really good they were
really great visuals yeah I agree with
that the whole thing with Galactus and
the cosmic and it actually keep it in
Galactus obscured and not seeing because
I'll show you what like I'll show you
what Galactus looks like oh fun photo
let's go on a Galactus Adventure by no
means like a Galactus experts I've heard
about Galactus for so long I feel like
you're saying Galactus a lot yeah
you feel like we've been building a
Galactus for so long the MCU that I've
become so yeah oh that's what he's doing
that's what it looks like yeah so cool
at first I was confused like okay I
guess it's just a energy entity thingy
and then you would see elements and
hints at its face just very obscure but
I actually like the way they realize him
for this go around and I think it would
have been a little too much if they just
made it like I'm another being you know
yeah because it is but to keep it
focused on Silver Surfer and and the
flipperoo that's where I was going I
thought the first Surfer was a good
person so they have to have the flipper
there I like Silver Surfer performance a
lot the comments heck yeah the body
language and voice of launch fishron I
like this one the first half hour that
was a little rough it was a little slow
and I was like why is the wedding the
villain here I'm tired of it like oh we
like oh my God yeah but then it picked
up yeah I think in the first half hour
oh I was like everyone's full of [__]
this is not better this is not the
better one this is actually feeling more
tedious it was at the when the when he
started rushing through the wedding when
I was like huh oh it's getting good oh
this is a better movie yeah this is a
better movie overall I just I felt like
it especially in the beginning there was
all this talk of the wedding and they
always pushed Jessica Alba's character
into like well I need to write
invitations and I have to dress to get
to and there's just there's no time like
they pushed her into this like she just
cares about a wedding and like being a
wife so much and then he's like don't
tell don't tell her that I'm I'm doing
the right thing that we all are here for
with our superpowers like as if she
would be like no no you're not gonna and
it's so funny because that was another
part that I was upset about because I'm
like she's literally never said don't
make that thing she probably would have
been like yeah we can postpone a couple
of days because it's not like you're
sleeping with some people with your
bachelor party you're making a thing to
save the world right that kind of
annoyed me that they were like don't do
it's a hush I thought they had
zero chemistry the first time around
Jessica and Reed yeah I know I keep
calling her Jessica what's her storm Sue
storm yeah yeah yeah I thought they had
zero chemistry this time this time I
actually believed him as a couple yes I
believe Johnny and uh Sue as brother and
sister yeah I I liked all that much more
and even for what they did with because
yeah it is in the first one especially
she is just you're hot and I think they
I think she was she's taught publicly
about it that they told her she had to
just pretty much be a pretty like they
didn't want her to come across
um smart capable yeah like oh
interesting and I think they they
transitioned her like I really like the
wrap around at the end where she's the
one rushing through the wedding that
she's not like not like oh come on rage
like she's the one like we gotta hurry
this up you know like okay this is that
that actually absolved a lot of that for
me to watch her and to have the
connection with Silver Surfer granted
she is just like you know the woman
still looked like you remind me all
these planets and there's only one
person right this whole time yeah my
wife uh so yeah I I still overall liked
her I like what they do with Johnny a
lot more too because oh yeah he really
grew yeah because that [__] could have
gotten old but they they matured him
here
except for the burning the the flowers
at the end
he's not gonna fully change I mean yes
he changed a little bit in a good way
the first one had it with the thing more
of a character here he's just kind of to
the side I don't really recall what he
did I know he did some stuff
what do you mean like
did he do anything in this movie
like
he punched something once in a while he
held that he held up that that Ferris
wheel or something yeah he said flame on
twice the thing yeah the flame on thing
what do you mean it's the flame on he
said flame on twice that's what he did
Ben Grimm the rock thing said oh my God
you said that you were talking I thought
you were talking about storm I said the
thing like twice oh you did yeah my bad
you're not listening obviously not of
acting is listening yeah I know and
reacting reacting is actually the
biggest part people apparently they say
that they're like acting is reacting and
I'm like all right everybody calm down
yeah if it goes in one ear not the other
I'm trying to think about my line is
come on boys come on now the thing what
did he do he he he was like listen I'll
stop this rock and that hurt and he said
clobber in time once
that's it oh and he brought his own big
cups to the bar because he's learned
he's learned and
um
he kind of
um he he did the flame thing with his
finger so it kind of Justified like oh
your power your flame on boy Power is
cool because he got to experience it
that's what he did you know I don't
um
I like the I like the relationship that
he forms with Johnny too here yeah it's
much better it's like it's like right
they they kind of become there's an
understanding now yeah the more of a
Brotherhood
you know what's weird is a Tim's Tim's
story the director of this he did barber
shop he did the shaft movie he just did
a movie that came out over the weekend I
think it's called the blackening got
great reviews another comedy okay got
amazing it's got amazing reviews and
and yet I feel like his weakest spot in
this movie is a comedy yeah and you're
saying Tim's story directed The
blackening Yeah Tim stores that like
he's mainly he does comedies he does
like what are the other things he's done
I just listed them you listed one Harbor
shop the latest Shaft movie
oh my God oh my God I really maybe I'm
not but I have I don't think there's a
maybe here it's like I'm 100 confident
you're you're just frankly like not
listening at all anything I'm saying
I'm trying to help out I haven't seen I
don't think it's been a long time since
I've seen the barbershop the latest you
did right along and ride along too okay
Think Like a Man Too
Kevin Hart what now it was very funny I
did laugh at that and Kevin Hart is
hilarious so okay he does comedy but
like that's mostly Kevin Hart driving
the comedy
still has like direct the movie you're
still like disregarding Kevin Hartz also
does some comedies that are not funny
you still need a good directory under
recognizing that he's good the effort
that director makes to assemble a film
he's good I mean the the visual effects
in this and everything else great
they're just like we were saying like
the comedy didn't really hit home for me
I wish they would have done like
alternates and been like should we test
these jokes to see if the pacing and the
delivery works like let's have some
alternates and if those were the
alternates and they put it in then I'm
like yeah I guess they didn't have like
that one that bear in the woods thing
I'm like like do you just not know what
to do with with the thing so you're
you're you're throwing in like this
random joke that's not funny at all it
looks very expensive because I think
that's a real bear yeah and also him
blowing his nose I was like what why are
they doing these little bits with him
and I'm like I'm not laughing at him
being like
yeah I don't think they knew what to do
um with that but the action was cool
this time around yeah I liked the first
fight with Silver Surfer when Johnny's
chasing him and everything on the
freeway all the absorption and energy
added material shifting things were
awesome too uh I was I was surprised by
how much more I I liked that I thought
this would just be a a better version
there's more they felt like a real team
Reed actually feels like a leader yes
finally I I felt that moment where he
stood up
yeah
unreasonable Channel quarterback he's
like you've now I'm the quarterback yeah
I'm I'm the quarterback now uh that
moment was good the
the over overall yeah I don't really
have too many qual I mean the first one
was just kind of like so like all right
that's done
um fine and I'm using entertainment like
the first one's probably more
more naturally like it had funnier
moments but yeah what I didn't like was
Doom I did not I like the way Doom looks
I could not I understand they're going
for he's power hungry and whatever like
I totally get that the choice though for
me
was like this is so illogical what he's
doing though I agree because he's gonna
die in the process right this is so
stupid what he's doing he brings in
Galactus like he's gonna die too yeah
there's no way he can defeat this guy
this the Galactus he doesn't know what
he's dealing with and clearly like
listen and I understand the choice like
he's so power hungry such a narcissist
he's so eager so he's not gonna listen
like yeah sure okay whatever it still
rings as stupid to me it was it was dumb
to me yeah and it felt like it was just
prolonging the run time here and they
just wanted to hit their 90 minute mark
on their film yeah because it's funny
because in the first movie Von Doom was
like a smart guy that ran this big
business even though it didn't really
fully succeed but he did make that thing
he went out into space and like whatever
yeah he was a guy that like built this
strong Empire right and then it just
sort of skipped to like him being healed
up but like a Darth Vader like and then
healing up to take another power and I'm
like bro like don't you have stuff to do
yeah like and I didn't get the general
um
yeah is there something I completely
missed about him getting on board with
it Doom just [__] teaming up with him
because I understand he had information
off the off the of the surveillance
thing on his helicopter that he gathered
but after that it's like do you try to
read like [__] Von Doom is clearly a bad
guy in the first like remember the
horrendous crimes he did and the first
one to the point you had to lock him in
a freaking crater and yeah ship him off
he was clearly a bad guy
so I think his service was done by that
point and they didn't even treat him
remotely close to being a prisoner they
he was he was like you're a buddy you
know at the whole time he just like got
to do whatever he wanted which is why it
made me so mad that they kept yelling at
Reed and I'm like Reed has been the only
one basically working for you and then
they they've blatantly say out loud when
the sergeant is there of like looks like
I'm doing it alone now and then Jessica
Alba storm goes to look for uh Doom yeah
because she's like I've got a brain
right now in this movie and why isn't he
here helping him
um which she had much more of a brain in
this film I feel like for sure which I
liked
um but I found that awe that I'm like
why wouldn't like why is no one calling
him out beside storm like being like why
aren't you here helping I brought the
sergeant brought Doom there to help them
and then reads like I guess I'm doing it
alone now and nobody else questions it
yeah yeah that was that was was a little
odd to me that was definitely odd
because he's down there making his arm
stuff so he can do the juice you know
yeah that was good stuff
overall though I thought the dramatic
scenes had a lot better I took it I was
able to take it serious the only part
that would pull me out is someone is the
comedy but then when it's when it's
sincere heart shined through yes when it
had those little bits of humor I like I
like those moments like the end when
they're all hugging each other I'm like
I really feel this it doesn't feel
forced like I feel this moment right
yeah even Silver Surfer being like she's
right there everyone has a choice like
you tell her that I'm like I feel this
moment I like that I actually am feeling
stuff for this movie versus the last one
which is kind of a blank experience of
amusement to me yeah yeah
um that I was I I thought this had more
of the emotional high notes and it's I
feel like even a third film would have
improved it uh that much more so it's
nice to see that there's an improvement
on this and I can under I I wonder if
this one was a box office failure let's
look it up let's look it up before
wrapping up this video and like when he
said dad would be proud I like that a
lot between him and his sis I believe
that and I was like that's so sweet I
felt like Tim's story heard the
criticism and knew how to to switch it
see the the first half hour though felt
like it was having some growing pains in
the shifting and then this one
I still did really well I don't know why
they didn't get a third one what
happened here the first one it only made
30 okay it cost 30 million dollars more
but made 30 million dollars less
um which is I mean a lot of times
sequels will not make as much money
but that's pretty close it's not like it
fell complete like for a movie that was
so panned by audiences and critics to
still come back with that I don't know
maybe it just still wasn't strong
um or maybe this one just kind of
because I know that I know both of these
movies have more of a Nostalgia now oh
my God they list Galactus right there in
the plot description they do Universal
certificates
so good I guess and then I was like I
could have just read the plot
description this whole time
all righty uh what would you give it out
of ten
um
the seven I would say a seven as well
last one was like a
like harsh and so like yeah five and a
half six yeah this one seven like a
seven a seven point five this hovers the
ending is really was my favorite part I
was like the ending and what is
happening here I liked all of it skip to
the end burn the flowers blah blah blah
they all go off and I was like yeah I
like it there's solid stuff all around
glad we could do this franchise together
Tara yeah yeah now there's another one
another
they re they decided to reboot it oh
and uh
it's called fan it's Fantastic Four yeah
and they wanted to go for a serious dark
approach really telling you right now
it was not well received really it was
worse
it is like really bad or what
I've seen it twice you've seen it twice
I'm half tempted just to watch it again
with you yeah duh what are you talking
about there's another one it's dark I
gotta see it
we have to do it now it's not good
am I going to be suffering like through
it how long is it
90 minutes of a bad movie I can do it's
on I just want you to ex it starts off
like this is all right two what's
happening
2015. I want to say
an hour and 40 minutes
140. see people called it
oh okay fan four Stick because they put
the four for some reason as the a
yeah
it's got Michael B Jordan
oh I love him but I love
um um
thank you so much
I love miles I want to watch it he's
great just to see your reaction why
haven't I seen this who is the who's
storm Kate Mara okay
and who is that Michael Chiclet still or
no that is not Michael chicken okay and
they don't make they don't make him
practical effects
oh they did he's all CG
I don't like it
okay I'm half tempted to just
I think you should be fully tempted to
just we're gonna have to watch it it's
just so I could see her okay sit here I
love all those actors I'm like it's
really it's that like not good but well
who directed it the 2015 one a guy named
Josh trank okay
I don't know it's sofa there's a whole
story behind everything that went wrong
with that movie really this is just a
disaster show behind the scenes and it
shows on screen seems like just like a
glamor magazine gossip column waiting to
be read yeah AKA by me the behind the
scenes is more interesting than the
actual
can we like watch it and then we look up
the behind the scenes juice after
right that's the real movie
well guys yeah where do you rank Rise of
the Silver Surfer leave your thoughts
down below be sure to subscribe leave a
like ring it a bell ring it a bell ring
of the Bell that was a new song I just
made up right now I would give it
four and a half Stars let's end this
with the patron of the day okay let's do
it aniso liver if I was Galactus I'd
want to devour you I feel like eating
you would also allow me to consume your
energy and soul which is so kind and
giving
fortuitous sympathetic
and I feel like I could finally be a
good person but it starts by doing an
evil deed first yeah an ironic part
which would be I'd have to first murder
you by swallowing you the value would be
good that I would be good so you'd be
doing even a good deal what you'd be a
better person by sacrificing yourself
yeah like to surf in silver like the
surf and silver you would be a better
person by just allowing yourself to die
to make me a better person and then and
make my time here more enjoyable and
then Tara whatever is a really
really you gotta go Anisa yeah you gotta
go you've got a skedat and by skadat
mean get eaten get eaten hi Gregory out
you won't even be buried six feet under
you would just be digested living in
there yeah
yeah okay well that's a good talk I hope
you I hope you uh you know get your will
going right the stuff down that you want
to give away and like when do you plan
on eating here soon or like are you
gonna wait
I'm gonna wait for a live stream oh oh
good good good so you have to invite her
over right to like you yeah because like
Galactus like devours I'm thinking going
bit by bit on you and Easter oh like
[__] knife if you Super Chat five
dollars we do a toe amazing
zero hopefully you know
um so I feel like it could be a real
good morbid experience and you got to be
awake for it
okay yeah that's that's a tough one
that's a real sacrifice but again would
take would make my time here more
enjoyable and and would take him into
into goodness into the goodness land
well let's let's face it that live
streams I couldn't be monetized on
playback so we need to get as much super
chats yes I mean you better be chatting
it and it better be super yeah getting
it done otherwise I'm stuck here with
him as he is and we all know that is
not anything I would normally sign up
for but you know I sacrificed my time to
be here for you guys
you know because I know it makes it
easier on you guys when I'm here because
him on his own is just like well
it's Greg again
you know
I don't ever say one main thing about it
thanks Anisa
[Music]